So if you said silicone is what Kim Kardashian
and Silicon Valley have in common, creative,
but that's not where I'm going with this.
Here's why.
Because there's a difference between silicon,
which is a 14th element on the periodic table
vs. silicone, which is a synthetic substance
that people use for many different things
that you can figure out, but this isn't that
video for it.
Let me tell you why it's a waste of time for
you to constantly compare your business to
Silicon Valley and Kim Kardashian.
You are guaranteed to be disappointed, 100%
to be disappointed.
Here's why.
They're celebrities.
They're on T.V.
Magazines love writing about it.
MSNBC news, MSN money, all these channels
love talking about companies in Silicon Valley.
They're going public, they're amazing, they're
this, they're that.
And so all these young entrepreneurs say,
"Oh my gosh, I want to be like those guys.
I want to start a technology company out of
Silicon Valley.
But what they don't realize is the following.
Only 4% of Fortune 500 companies are based
out of Silicon Valley.
Only five-and-a-half, six percent of Forbes
400 richest people are based out of Silicon
Valley.
Only that much.
Now watch this here.
I want you to keep this in mind.
When we're saying only five or six percent,
stay here with me.
Why should I not want to be like Silicon Valley
or Kim Kardashian?
Here's why.
#1: It's simply reality T.V.
Kim Kardashian's life, is not real.
It's reality T.V. to get millions of people
to watch, not for you to say, "I want to be
Kim Kardashian one day" because it's not real.
It's fake.
Silicon Valley, it's fake.
It's a small little bubble that they have.
It's not real business.
The way they run their businesses is not the
way you run 99.9% of businesses around the
world, around the country.
#2: Math never makes sense.
How did Kim become famous?
It's the question everybody asks.
How did this company pay $20 billion to this
business and this business only does $400
million a year of revenue?
Why did Facebook pay so much money to Instagram?
Instagram wasn't even making money.
What happened there?
The math doesn't make sense.
So you running a business, a real, legitimate
business, that you can show math, it's different
than Silicon Valley.
#3, you'll be disappointed if you compare,
100% of the time.
Well, when I look at Kim's life and I look
at these people in Silicon Valley, they're
businesses are so amazing.
I must be a terrible CEO or entrepreneur or
this or that, you're not.
Listen, let me tell it to you in a completely
different way.
I'm here to tell you, I'm willing to tell
you this.
The guy that's running a business, doing $17
million a year with his or her business, that
she grew, from zero to $17 million a year,
she may be as good as a CEO as any of those
CEOs in Silicon Valley.
Yes!
Absolutely!
Why?
Because in Silicon Valley, one can go raise
money and get $10 million round one, 50 round
two, $200 round three, and they bring the
right people around.
They had one great idea, it blows up, and
then they say, this guy's the greatest CEO
of all time.
But the person who's $17 million may be a
better CEO.
You can't compare yourself on what Silicon
Valley does.
Next, they live on an island of their own.
It's a completely different island.
They go in a completely different community.
These guys grow up in a different school,
college environment, the restaurants, the
places, they're in a completely different
environment than you are, maybe out of Toledo,
or maybe out of Duluth or maybe out of you
know, Austin, or Jacksonville or some of these
cities that you may be a part of, a completely
different life.
#5, few duplicatable habits.
You know what's a duplicatable habit?
What Sam Walton did is duplicatable.
What Jeff Bezos did, is duplicatable habits.
What people take regular businesses and they
build it into conglomerates, those are duplicatable
habits that you could do.
Here's why.
Let me remind you of this.
Sixty percent, listen, warning sign, 60% of
Fortune 500 companies from 1970 are no longer
around today.
Do you know what that means?
Here's 500 companies, 300 of them, gone!
Only 200 of them are around from 1970.
What does that mean to you?
Hmmm. . . that means Silicon Valley may be
nothing 40 years from now.
And no one even talks about it except for
textbooks in universities to say mistakes
that were made.
or things they did right.
Now I'm not telling they don't do a lot of
things right.
I use a lot of their companies and I invest
into them.
But to use your business based on how they
do it, don't forget that this [going out of
business] can happen.
If you go to a place where everybody goes
to and it's already predictable, you're leaving
all the other opportunities that no one is
even paying attention to.
Now, having said that, let me tell you duplicatable
way that you could do something to build your
business, something that is completely different
than this reality T.V. that they live in.
Very simple.
Typically, here's how somebody becomes an
entrepreneur.
They learn how to sell.
They learn how to create, because they shadow
somebody.
So I work under somebody and I'm like, man,
this guy this is how he sells.
This is great, I can do this as well.
Here's how he makes phone calls.
I can do this as well.
Dude, did you see what he.
. . I can do that as well.
I analyze it, and shadow someone.
They see somebody designs, creates something.
They build this desk, they build this car,
they build an engine.
Man, I shadow them.
I see this is kind of cool.
I can do this.
Or they broker a product.
They sell real estate.
They sell insurance.
They sell them as they're brokering somebody
else's product that they didn't create themselves.
But they learned how to broker that product.
They do this for a while, and then you save
money.
You save 10 grand, 20 grand, 50 grand, 100
grand, 200, 300, of your own money, in your
pocket, because you did this for a couple
of years.
Then you save your money, then you show proof
that you know what you're doing in an industry
you become an expert, you and a group of people
decide to start a business, and you own a
piece of the company.
You and the people that started a business
together.
Then you raise money.
Then you build your business.
Then you either sell it off or keep growing
your company.
This, my friends, is duplicatable.
This is reality T.V.
So in closing, if you compare your personal
life to our friend, Kim Kardashian, or if
you run your business and you compare yourself
to all the people in Silicon Valley, you're
bound to be disappointed and discouraged with
yourself.
Focus on your game.
Focus on the fundamentals.
Focus on what works.
Focus on growing your base, your business,
your company, your life, your personal life,
see what you can do to make that better.
And believe me, a big victory could be around
the corner for you as well, if you do it right.
If you've got any questions, comments, thoughts,
comment on the bottom.
If you have any friends in Silicon Valley,
be sure to share this video with them because
I'm sure they're going to love this video.
And if you haven't subscribed to this channel,
sub here, join the notification squad by clicking
on the alert button as well.
Take care everybody.
Bye, bye.